quando eu conto para as pessoas que eu
sou skatista profissional
a primeira coisa que acontece é que elas
não acreditam e a segunda coisa é que em
90% dos casos as pessoas fala ah ja
tentei andar de skate
mas eu cair quando vocês aqui já a
tentar andar de skate cair alguma vez
praticamente todo mundo então vou contar
pra vocês o que aconteceu quando eu
tentei subir em cima do skate
eu caí e machuquei e algum tempo depois
de ter curado conseguido tirar o gesso
da perna
eu fui lá esteve de novo e continuo anda
aí depois de algum tempo eu participei
do meu primeiro campeonato e eu fiquei
em antepenúltimo no cap último foi o
antepenúltimo
isso despertou em mim o sentimento de eu
não posso ser tão ruim assim porque no
dia a dia o ano bem mas na hora do
campeonato eu fiquei lá pra última
preciso fazer alguma coisa para mudar é
preciso fazer alguma coisa para melhorar
e aí a primeira lição que aprendi com o
skate foi você vai cair você vai cair o
tempo inteiro você vai cair mais do que
você vai ficar de pé e é por isso que
aprender a cair é mais importante do que
aprendendo a aprender a ficar de pé ea
segunda coisa que você precisa saber é o
que te motiva a levantar porque para
levantar você precisa ter uma motivação
e você tem que levantar rápido pra
tentar de novo
esse é um gráfico meio imaginário dos
dias que eu ando de skate num dia que eu
tô tranquila e vôos em foco profissional
eu passo 50% do tempo descansando 31%
acertando e 18% cain agora num dia que
eu vou tentar uma manobra desafiadora eu
passo 89 por cento caindo 10% e
descansando e 1% acertando esse 1% é
equivalente a 5 segundos
nas outras três horas
andando eu simplesmente estou cometendo
um erro atrás de erro e juntando essas
duas coisas que são os dias de zona de
conforto e os dias que você se puxa um
pouco mais porque as coisas costumam
acontecer quando a gente sai da nossa
zona de conforto é que gera a evolução e
esse é o motivo para continuar é buscar
a evolução é ser melhor amanhã do que eu
fui ontem mas sem perder o foco no
presente
curtindo o meu momento e não pensando no
que já aconteceu ou no que está para
acontecer
eu acho que a minha melhor manobra é a
que está sempre por vir
eu nunca me conformo com que eu já fiz
eu sempre busco novo e acho que eu
consigo me superar a cada dia ea cada
vez que eu ano
isso faz com que eu seja uma pessoa
aberta para novas oportunidades e pra
aprender com os meus próprios erros e
buscar novos conhecimentos e está aberta
a pessoas que tenham alguma coisa para
ensinar ou situações que têm alguma
coisa para me ensinar também e acho que
isso é uma característica em comum das
pessoas que são bem sucedidas no momento
de campeonato acontece um fato peculiar
de repente você para escutar música você
para de enxergar as pessoas que estão à
sua volta e só o que importa o que você
tem a fazer e é uma coisa que eu não
conseguiria explicar para vocês é uma
coisa que tem que ser sentida ser mulher
no esporte predominantemente masculino
podia ser uma limitação mas acabou sendo
minha maior força porque eu sempre tive
certeza do que o que eu estava fazendo
era bom é certa o seu primeiro em
qualquer coisa que vocês façam é
explorar o território que não tem mata
você não sabe o que vai acontecer depois
é desafiador mas não é impossível
não é impossível ele só nunca foi feito
antes mas alguém tem que ir lá e fazer e
vale a pena porque depois você percebe o
quanto isso inspira outras pessoas para
que venham atrás de você a fazerem o
mesmo
outra pergunta que sempre me fazem
eu sofri preconceito se o preconceito
existe o preconceito existe é óbvio só
que eu percebi que o tempo inteiro eu
estava distraída de mais focada nas
manobras que eu ia aprender ou nos
campeonatos que eu queria ganhar a
atenção pra ele então de alguma forma
ele me perseguia e eu ia dando olé
lidando com ferramentas que eu julgava
serem as melhores porque eu percebi que
a mudança ela não é racional
ela é política então eu sempre tentei
ligar lidar com inteligência em vez de
força ea resposta para essas pessoas
veio não em forma de palavras mas em
forma de acontecimentos
o skate de 2009 para 2015 passou de 4
milhões de praticantes pra 8.5 milhões
de praticantes sendo 19% são meninas e
as pessoas me perguntam também se eu não
tenho medo e é óbvio que eu tenho medo
não sou louca
só que eu não fico pensando no medo toda
vez que eu dropou o que eu coloco meu
skate no pé
eu penso que eu vou cair de cara eu
penso que vou ficar em cima que eu vou
acertar me perguntam também se eu tenho
vergonha e eu tinha muita vergonha
só que eu percebi que as pessoas também
estavam ocupadas fazendo as coisas delas
e elas não estavam olhando tanto pra mim
quanto eu pensava que ela estava
a gente tem mania de pensar que a gente
é o centro do universo né
mas eu acho que eu aprendi com cada erro
todas as vezes que eu cair eu percebi
que eu estava mais perto do acerto
cada vez que eu errava eu sabia o que eu
tinha que não fazer e eu entendi a qual
era o caminho para chegar no meu
objetivo
ou seja eu concluir que a minha próxima
manobra minha melhor manobra ela vai
chegar é só uma questão de tempo e
persistência
[Aplausos]
[Música]